- Thank you.
- Y'all look so fabulous right now.
Both of you complimenting each other.
- You guys look beautiful.
- It's like you're in a video.
- We are working it.
- Looks beautiful.
- So last time you were here,
you were going to college, right?
You were on your way?
- I was on the way to college.
- [Kelly] Is it USC?
- I'm at USC.
- [Kelly] How's it going?
- It's so good.
I'm in my sophomore year, second semester.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I've been very busy.
I missed the first part
of my first semester.
- [Kelly] Because of Covid.
- Because of Covid
and like working and
things of that nature.
But I just can't wait to be back
and I mean it's very important
for me to not only pursue my acting career
but furthering my education
is very important.
So I'm glad that I just
could balance both.
(people clap)
- Well that's an
incredibly hard thing to do
to balance both.
- Yes. It is.
- I think going to school too,
it only helps you with acting
and then acting only helps,
so all of that can help you.
- Exactly. It all informs each other.
All helps each other.
- Yeah, agreed.
- Well I mentioned Euphoria,
which you starred with Zendaya
and I didn't know this
but the first time you met her,
we found this picture.
Look at her in this photo.
- [Storm] I was a baby.
- [Kelly] She is a baby.
- [Marcia] Oh my God baby, baby, baby.
- [Kelly] I mean, what kinda
life do you have to where
you meet her as a young
and then now you've worked with her?
- It's wild.
It's a blessing.
- [Kelly] That's crazy.
- Yeah. That was at the
Ben and Jerry's in Burbank.
I was on the way.
- First of all nice choice.
- Yeah!
- Half-Baked my favorite.
- [Storm] Exactly.
- [Kelly] Nice.
- I was there. I was
about to go to the AMC
and I heard a familiar voice.
And you know when you
hear a familiar voice
you turn around.
I was ordering my ice
cream and then I just look
over my shoulder and she's right there.
And I literally stood there
for probably about two minutes
and I was just like.
And my mom was like,
"You're being embarrassing.
You're either gonna go say hi
or don't say anything at all."
And now we're like, she's my big sis.
We get to work together.
And I just admire and love her.
- I just love that. That is, you know,
sometimes we can harp on this city
for a lot of things that aren't great
but it's a beautiful
dreamer's place, you know?
It is.
- [Storm] Absolutely.
- [Kelly] It's really cool
that you dream like
that when you're a kid.
You have this goal,
you meet this person that inspires you
and you end up working.
That's a really cool story.
- Exactly. It's very cool.
(people cheer)
- So I heard Storm that you
bought your mama a house.
- I did.
- How did that feel?
- Oh, it was so good
It feels so good.
- I imagine, because
you're a young actress
so she probably had to
sacrifice quite a bit.
- Absolutely.
My mom has made so many sacrifices for me.
There we are.
She's made so many sacrifices for me.
So to be able to come to LA from Atlanta,
we didn't have much.
And to build the house in California.
- [Marcia] Yeah.
- It's a surreal experience
and something that I'm still processing
and trying to be grateful for.
But I think it's also a really cool thing
where I get to pat myself on the back.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- And just see my mom happy
and renovate and decorate.
She's like in her element,
living her best life.
So it makes me happy.
- That's just the coolest
thing be able to do.
(people clap)
- What was your favorite thing that
you maybe bought your mom?
- Oh I took mine both on
a trip to New Zealand.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's incredible.
- And so memories have become
a really important part
for me and my mom.
My mother passed from
Alzheimer's and one of the things
I bought for her before she
passed was an Aura frame.
And I literally should be the spokesperson
for Aura frames.
- Is that the one that
rotates the pictures?
- Yes. And anybody can
email their pictures,
the family can all email.
And so she would have
all these familiar faces
all the time passing through.
- That's kind of an
incredible gift for someone
with dementia to always be
reminded of these faces.
- Yes, to be reminded.
Even if she didn't always know,
I remember once she said to me,
"I don't know who you are,
but I know you're important to me."
And you're like, "That's
all you need to know Mom."
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Important to you.
But now I'm a little upset
I didn't buy her a house.
- [Storm] Awe.
(people laugh)
- Yeah, you took her to New Zealand.
- [Marcia] I did.
- Also just made me cry.
So you're doing fine.
- [Marcia] It was such a beautiful time.
- So your new movie also deals
with a mother-daughter relationship.
It's called Missing.
So can you tell everybody about it?
- Yes. So I have a movie,
Missing, where I play June.
A stubborn young teenage girl
just really trying to figure out life.
Who she want to be.
- Never met one.
Never been one.
(people laugh)
- So she's just really
trying to figure out life.
And her mom, Grace, goes on vacation
to Colombia with her boyfriend
and ends up going missing.
So June has to try to figure
out where her mother is through
technology and social media.
And it's different from any type of,
I guess other mysterious crime movie.
Because it's all taking place
through my POV on computer screens.
So you never actually
leave the computer screen
while you're watching this movie.
- That's interesting.
- Yeah. It was technically challenging.
Just the different eye lines
and filming on a phone
and computer and a watch.
Which is crazy to me.
But it was a lot of fun.
- Oh my gosh.
So is your mom in real
life good with tech?
- I think she wishes she was better.
She's not bad.
- That means that means not good.
(people laugh)
- No, it was just a big no.
- Yeah. That's a hard no.
- The emails, the phone calls, the texts,
she's got it all covered.
And like the DocuSigns.
Anything where she has to be in work mode,
she's got. But the Instagram
and anything other than work stuff.
She's like, "Storm help me."
And it's just one button and
I'm like, "Here you go mom."
- It's not just one button, Storm.
- I'm sorry.
- Coming from other mothers
- And the remote,
they make the little icons this big.
I'm like, what is it?
What does it say to do?
I can't see the damn thing.
- Why do you need three?
- [Marcia] Why?
- I got in, they installed it
and I'm just like there
are three remotes here.
- [Marcia] Right.
- What the hell are they all for?
- I had to call my son
from dance class one time,
he was in school, away
in a boarding school.
I had to call him from dance class and say
"How do you turn the TV on Hudson Shield?"
(people laugh)
- He was like, "Mom!"
- And you're like, "I'm being serious.
Tell me you're not getting off the phone."
- I'm serious.
That's right. That's exactly true.
- It's hard sometimes.
I mean, not for me. I'm so good at this.
Let's see a clip of the movie.
Here is Storm Reid in Missing.
(phone rings)
- [Nia] Siri. Call June.
- [Storm] Oh my gosh, Mom.
- [Nia] Siri please call June Bug.
- [Storm] Mom you're already
on the phone this is FaceTime.
- Oh gosh.
- You know you don't have to use Siri
for literally everything right?
- Listen, I need you to write
a couple of things down.
The car keys are going
to be in the top drawer
in the kitchen. And Kevin...
I just said write it down.
You're not writing it down.
No alcohol and keep your location service
turned on the entire time I'm away.
Do you understand?
- No fun, got it.
(people clap and cheering)
- The best part.
Z U F Y
- Wasn't even typing anything.
- Yeah, got it. Clear.
Missing is now in theaters
and Marcia's film,
Daughter of the Bride, comes
out February 3rd y'all.